we had the occasional guest related
Fiasco last-minute today and that seems
to happen to us about every three to
four months so we are going to go to the
phones and take a few phone calls right
after the first day of Donald Trump's
Senate impeachment trial the number of
course is six one seven eight three zero
forty seven fifty want to see what is on
people's minds let's start today with
our caller from the three four six area
code caller from three four six what's
your name and where you calling from I
gave the good morning my name is Jacob
I'm calling from Denver hey Jacob what's
up I'm a third year law student and
about to graduate got a very simple
question for you what do you make of the
Trump campaign or not the Trump campaign
the Trump Whitehouse recruiting Alan
Dershowitz
for his defense yeah we we talked about
this a little bit I mean listen I
there's Trump chooses lawyers and
chooses staff very much by media
presence and Alan Dershowitz has become
a big media defender of Donald Trump's I
don't know what wider stir wits is doing
it I don't think it's for the money well
there so it's his you know 80 years old
and more than wealthy enough that he
doesn't need to make another dollar for
the rest of his life it may be that he
likes the idea of being publicly
associated with and in cahoots with and
hanging out with a sitting president I
don't really know what's up with Alan
Dershowitz but the reason Trump chose
him is because Dershowitz very publicly
publicly defends him and Trump just
loves having people around him that are
in media saying things that Trump wants
to hear quite plainly think it's I think
it's absolutely incredible that
Dershowitz is still working the media I
mean made a humungous name for himself
with the OJ trial and it's it's just
interesting from a law student
perspective to view what's going on well
it's also interesting because during the
Clinton impeachment Dershowitz and
Kenneth Starr were on opposite sides and
Dershowitz actually said Kenneth Starr
is dangerous in what he was doing to
Bill Clinton now Trump has hired both
Dershowitz and Kenneth Starr now the
together right how do you think this
impeachment Senate trial is going to be
different than the Clinton trial
well it's it's 20 years later right so
the media environment is so drastically
different that they're you know Fox News
exists there is an entire cottage
industry of people writing books and
having media presences either on their
own programs or going on other people's
programs solely based on defending
Donald Trump no matter what he does
that's going to make this so different
from what happened with Bill Clinton and
the media is a huge part of what makes
that different social media as well with
the 24-hour news cycle I mean how is
that going to affect this senator I mean
this this story has I think defeated
that kind of 24-hour news cycle I mean
it's on all the time everyone's talking
about it what's going to change how is
this rapid news cycle going to be
different well again because you have a
constant streaming of everything online
the ability to at any time of day go and
find opinion about how Trump is either
obviously guilty or obviously innocent
it's just going to further reinforce the
echo chambers where when you had you
know 30-minute nightly news summing up
what took place that day it did not
allow for these unbreakable echo
chambers that we now see Jacob I'm gonna
let you go appreciate the phone call
I've got a bunch of people waiting to
get on let's go next to our caller from
the 7-1 six area code who's calling
today from seven one six I gave it this
is Sean from Buffalo hey Sean what's up
I wanted to know what your stance on
infant male circumcision is oh I'm for
parents basically deciding what they
want to do as per the guidelines of the
American pediatric Association and we've
talked about it probably twenty or
thirty times on the show and I don't
have anything new to say about it what
do you make of the fact
it it's so much lower in many other
countries I don't make much of it quite
frankly are these countries just
negligent can even informed about the
benefits no I would not make any
assertion about how informed you know I
don't live in other countries so I
wouldn't be able to tell you their level
of informed or uninformed and the IEP no
longer recommended the procedure so why
would we continue doing it sorry the IEP
the ATP aap Oh feel free to send me
whatever report you're referring to and
I'll take a look at it okay all right
okay thanks very much